OF LIFE, LIBERTY AND LEVIN.
I CALL HIM THE GREAT ONE, MARK
LEVIN.
WE MISSED YOU AND ARE GLAD YOU
ARE BACK.
LET'S TALK ELECTION.
>> THANK YOU.
IT'S TIME FOR WE THE PEOPLE TO
STAND UP FOR OURSELVES.
FOR OUR FAMILIES.
FOR OUR FAITH.
FOR A COUNTRY AND OUR PARTY AND
PRESIDENT.
THE MEDIA HAVE INTERPOSED
THEMSELVES IN THIS ELECTION.
WE ARE FIGHTING THE MEDIA AND
THE DEMOCRATS AND FIGHTING
HOLLYWOOD AND ALL OF THE REST.
64% OF THE VOTERS SAY THE PRESS
HAS DONE MORE TO DIVIDE THE
COUNTRY.
MORE PEOPLE THINK THE PRESS HAS
DIVIDED THE COUNTRY THAN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
THE WORLD HITLER IS POPULAR WITH
THE PRESS.
WITH SCARBOROUGH AND WHITE
SUPREMACY IS POPULAR AT CNN.
THEY CONSIDER THOSE OF US WHO
SUPPORT THIS PRESIDENT AS NAZIS
AND RACISTS AND EVERY TIME THERE
IS A HORRIFIC EVENT THEY TRY TO
PIN IT ON US AND THE PRESIDENT.
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
WE CAN'T TURN ANY PART OF THIS
GOVERNMENT OVER TO THESE RADICAL
HARD-CORE DEMOCRATS AND THEIR
MOUTHPIECES IN THE MEDIA.
A FEW EXAMPLE.
THEY TALK ABOUT THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS RELATIONSHIP TO
VIOLENCE.
THE PRESIDENT HASN'T CAUSED ANY
WHEN ANTIFA IS BEATING UP PEOPLE
THE MEDIA HARDLY SAYS ANYTHING.
THE TERRORISTS WHO MURDERED 4
PEOPLE AND INJURED 44 OTHER
PEOPLE, I DON'T REMEMBER THEM
SAYING BILL CLINTON CONTRIBUTED
TO A VIOLENT TONE.
WHEN BARACK OBAMA COMMUTED THE
LEADER OF THAT ORGANIZATION WHO
NEVER REPRESENTED, THEY NEVER
BROUGHT THAT UP.
WHEN BARACK OBAMA BEFRIENDED THE
UNDERGROUND AND DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS I DON'T REMEMBER
ANYBODY TALKING ABOUT HIM AND
VIOLENCE.
OBAMA OPENS AN EMBASSY IN CUBA.
A POLICE STATE.
HE IS CELEBRATED.
DONALD TRUMP MOVES OUR EMBASSY
FROM TEL AVIV TO JERUSALEM AND
HE IS ATTACKED BY MSNBC.
LET'S TALK ABOUT IMMIGRATION.
DWIGHT EISENHOWER IS NOT A
RACIST IS HE?
DWIGHT WHEN HE BECAME PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES, HE CREATED
A PROGRAM CALLED OPERATION
WETBACK.
THAT'S NOT ME.
THAT WAS HIM.
WHAT WAS THAT?
HE ORDERED THE MILITARY TO
ROUNDUP 1.3 MILLION ILLEGAL
ALIENS AND DEPORT THEM.
THAT'S WHAT HE DID.
HE WAS SUPPORTED BY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY TOO.
1960s, CEASAR CHAVEZ THE FOUNDER
OF THE UNITED FARM WORKERS
UNION, HE ORDERED HIS MEMBERS AT
NIGHT TO WATCH THE SOUTHERN
BORDER AND REPORT ILLEGAL
ALIENS.
RALPH ABERR GNATHY WHO WAS
WORKING WITH MARTIN LUTHER KING
AND MONDALE, THEY LED PROTESTS
AGAIN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
THE PRESS SAYS DONALD TRUMP IS
THREATENING FREEDOM OF THE
PRESS.
HOW SO?
BY EXPOSING THEM?
JOHN ADAMS PUT IN PLACE THE
SEDITION ACT.
HE PUT JOURNALISTS IN PRISON.
LINCOLN PUTTON EXECUTIVE ORDER.
THEY SHUTDOWN 300 NEWSPAPERS AND
PUT THE JOURNALISTS AND EDITORS
IN PRISON.
AND WOODROW WILSON, HE HAD THE
SEDITION ACT OF 1918 AND DID THE
SAME THING.
PUT JOURNALISTS IN PRISON AND
SOME OF HIS OPPONENTS.
DONALD TRUMP HAS NOT DONE
ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
HE IS NOT ROUNDING UP LEGAL
IMMIGRANTS OR PUTTING
JOURNALISTS IN PRISON.
THEY REFER TO HIM AS HITLER AND
STALIN.
THEN, WE HAVE THIS POLICY WHERE
WE SEPARATE CHILDREN FROM THEIR
PARENTS WHO COME HERE ILLEGALLY
NOT BECAUSE WE WANT TO PUT THEM
IN CAGES LIKE OBAMA DID BUT TO
PROTECT THE CHILDREN FROM
COYOTES AND KID SNAPPER.
-- KIDNAPPERS.
IT WAS ROOSEVELT WHO PUT
JAPANESE-AMERICANS IN INTERNMENT
CAMPUS.
THEY DON'T CALL HIM HITLER OR
STALIN.
I WILL EVEN GO HERE.
THEY ATTACK OUR PRESIDENT.
THEY SAY A WOMANIZER AND BRING
STORMY DANIELS IN FRONT OF TV
LEFT AND RIGHT.
THIS PRESIDENT HAS BEEN OUR
PRESIDENT.
HE CONDUCTED HIMSELF IN THE OVAL
OFFICE WITH GREAT ACCUMEN.
PEOPLE ARE LAUGHING.
JFK HAD AFFAIRS CONSTANTLY WITH
A GERMAN SPY AND A 17-YEAR-OLD
INTERN AND HE WAS OUT DONE BY
RIDG
LBD
LBJ.
THEY ARE CAMPAIGNING AGAINST VAR
VALUES AND AGAINST THE
CONSTITUTION.
YOU HAVE A RARE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHOW YOURSELF.
STAND UP AND SAY WE ARE NOT
PUTTING UP WITH THIS ANYMORE.
WE WILL PROTECT OUR COUNTRY.
WE WILL PROTECT OUR VALUES AND
OUR  INSTITUTIONS AND OUR
PRESIDENT AND OURSELVES.
SICK OF BEING CALLED NAZI AND
RACISTS, YOU NEED TO VOTE NOW
AND VOTE TUESDAY AND BRING OUT 6
PEOPLE AND MAKE SURE YOU VOTE.
IF MORE OF US VOTE, WE WIN.
IF LESS OF THEM VOTE, THEY LOSE.
>> Sean: MARK LEVIN.
OUR CONDOLENS.
I KNEW YOUR DAD.
HE PASSED AWAY.
A GREAT MAN.